Biden tops Trump by two points in
hypothetical 2024 match-up Trails
DeSantis a new quinnipi quinnipeg
University poll finds that President
Biden is a in close hypothetical races
with two leading candidates Republican
parties 2024 nomination Biden leads
former president Trump in a hypothetical
2024 rematch with 48 support to Trump's
46 in a hypothetical election between
Biden and Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
the other front-runner for GOP Biden
Trails 46 to desantises 48. the poll
found Trump leading DeSantis in a
head-to-head but behind with the former
president earning 52 percent of the
census 42 Biden Trump and DeSantis all
at similar favorable ratings amongst
registered voters with 37 percent having
a favorable view of Biden 36 percent of
trump and 36 percent of the sentence so
in this case they're saying Trump beats
DeSantis but Trump doesn't beat Biden
and if DeSantis wins the scientists
could beat Biden how aligned are you
with what this poll is shown no I think
that that poll is very accurate what is
out there and it's interesting that you
know Ron DeSantis has those numbers he
hadn't even declared and so I think that
you will see an improvement in his
numbers if he declare look Ron DeSantis
won the State of Florida in his first
election by less than one percent over
Andrew Gillum right oh Andrew Gillen
mayor of Tallahassee what was the thing
that took Ron DeSantis over the top and
brought single black mothers to vote for
him educational Freedom school choice
that that is the Forefront issue right
now if that's what Trump would have said
it was him though yeah well that's the
thing leadership is not about first
person singular and if I could if he was
sitting right there I'd tell him that
you got to stop using first person
singular because that's not how you lead
people that's how you get the attention
on you but now that's been signed into
law here in in in Florida and when he
came back for his re-election I mean he
won Palm Beach County he won Miami-Dade
County he won by almost 20 percent never
happens where Republican carries
Miami-Dade County never one and a half
million by one and a half million votes
he would now the Dems will say Charlie
Chris has hands down the worst candidate
in the history of mankind every single
so is Joe Biden and and again you know
Charlie Chris was out there touting the
policies woke stuff and all this other
stuff that of Joe Biden the American
people were rejected if they had
something clear to this is just the same
as Jimmy Carter coming out in Ronald
Reagan remember that Ronald Reagan
commercial this morning in America who
could not vote for that there was only
one state in the United States of
America never voted for Ronald Reagan
that was Minnesota did you see did you
see yeah that's right 49 out of 50. and
by the way Carter is the Biden is the
closest thing to Carter if not well he's
not yet worse data wise but he's worse
than other ways at least Carter was
liked and you know he thought it was a
man a Navy Submariner uh Academy
graduate no one could sit and say Carter
hated America just the same as Bill
Clinton Bill Clinton pivoted after his
midterm debacle people will say Bill
Clinton love women more than America
that's an artist
well they were all American women but
yeah they were American women but Bill
Clinton Bill Clinton is the guy who
that was good you know that may be one
of your best he didn't like them first
American woman
[Laughter]
Thomas but you were saying Clinton
America I agree but Bill Clinton is the
guy who stood up in a state of Union
address and said the Arab big government
is over
do you think a Democrat could stand up
in the State of Union no and so that
that's why you know the blue dog demons
conservative demon whatever you want to
call it they don't exist anymore but the
thing is that we have to run on these
issues we have to get out there and find
out what are the the things that you
just you know talked about earlier what
brings us together
how can we Galvanize ourselves and and I
will tell you the the issue of Education
galvanizes this country it really does
because I think that parents are
concerned about the future for their
children
look at look at these inner cities I
mean Chicago Baltimore these kids cannot
function math and English a grade level
some fully agree with you I think I
think the
education in kids is is not a Republican
or Democratic argument it's all across
the board just like Roe v Wade if you
notice the stats on the midterms was
like Hey you know this is something that
if you pushed it the way you did you
know they said McConnell did this to
kind of hurt Trump's uh look to say he
lost on you read all those stories you
know what I'm talking about but there
are certain things that the American
people are saying leave this alone we're
kind of at this point here I think
education is being one of them so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign
[Music]